[Music]
so I get to answer your questions
stay tuned
Can You Feel the excitement America
President Biden teasing that you'll know
quote real soon about his 2024 plans
even though he's completely bombing in
the polls the big guy is expected to
officially kick off his bid for
re-election tomorrow with a low-key
video announcement he apparently filmed
it at his beach house after getting back
from his Ireland trip and while Biden
pushes ahead more than half the country
is saying no thanks a whopping 70
percent say Biden should not run again
and even the media has serious doubts
about Joe
the American people want that do they
want four more years for this president
in my own sense is that most Americans
don't want to vote for an 81 year old
man for president I
are the ones that I really worry about
right now they have got to get on it
what their message is going to be and
what they're going to do to build the
enthusiasm for their candidate president
is facing serious headwinds when it
comes to the public perception about
whether or not he should run and chief
among those concerns are the president's
80 year old age there's a majority of
Democrats who don't want to see Biden
run again it's not because of his
policies it's simply because of
questions about his physical ability to
do it in his current age
and while Americans have worries about a
second Biden term top Democrats are
trying to reassure them
he is going to have an incredibly strong
record to run on should President Biden
be doing more to show
Americans that he's up to the job
I think his schedule reflects an active
person mentally and physically who is
engaging with the American people on a
regular basis it's about 19 months
before there's an election most people
make their decision on the candidate 19
days before the election so we're far in
advance of any decision making
okay Greg I'm going to start with you
all right so what we've got is the
media's questioning Biden 70 of
Americans don't want them to run and the
truth is that when everyone is starting
to question them including the Democrat
Media or the mainstream media it's not a
good sign for this guy it's a pretty
staggering number I mean it's hard to
get 70 of anybody to believe in one
thing it's hard to get 70 percent I mean
to agree what a woman is uh what about
the remaining 30 percent I mean can you
do polling in psychiatric hospitals
whenever they describe somebody is
active that means they're really old
right oh he's so active yeah it's like a
13 year old dog trying to go up the
stairs uh but it is kind of funny when
you think about Joe we were having this
conversation in 2019 and everybody said
he was already past his prime shout out
to Don Lemon uh but who would think we
would have the same I know big Media
news today
I've seen that coming anyway uh but uh
we're having the same conversation again
at 2024. you know for 2020 it's like
it's like booking a second trip on the
Titanic and now we're in this era of
deep fakes and artificial intelligence
and where you're going to have a video
tomorrow I mean he's going to be as real
as Max Headroom you're going to be
moving around like this it'll be Clips
there'll be edits because you can't just
you can't just run it because it's not
going to work in his defense because
Harold is here and he needs all the help
he can get uh the generic candidate
always does better right than that
because the unknown is always preferable
to The Familiar you know every time we
fall in love it's before familiarity
kicks in and you have this person that
you admire and you love and then over
time you know you start to get tired of
them and it may not be their fault but
you know maybe it's because you're tired
of hearing the same thing and or maybe
they piss you off and then sooner or
later then it's just over and then
everybody's shocked
thank you you're welcome all right Dana
The Wall Street Journal says that Biden
is being selfish by saying that he's the
only guy for the job and possibly
leaving us stuck with Kamala Harris
um and especially now with the the fact
that it appears at this campaign
whenever it gets started is going to be
a very low-key campaign with a low key
announcement so do you guys remember in
one of the first Democratic primary
debates in back in 2019 it was um one it
was one of the Castro brothers that was
running for president and on stage
during the debate he brought up
cognitive decline yes yes and he was
almost run out of town he basically
dropped out a day or two later because
everyone said you can't say that well
now the New York Times editorial Pages
actually saying I'm not saying to drop
out but they are saying there is an
issue here and they're saying the
president needs to address it I I
remember when President Trump took
office the first day he announced that
day that he would be running for
reelection so there was never any
question but Biden has done for the past
18 months is let everybody wonder will
he will he run again
I think something that happened in the
midterms when they when the Democrats
did better than expected it's sort of
saddled the Democrats with Biden because
now he he doesn't think that he's old
okay and I think that it's hard to tell
somebody that and he has his family
around him saying it's all you're good
we're good to go and you've accomplished
so much you have to finish the job and
he believes that and they're going to
keep on trying to to push for that I do
think that they've been pretty open
about the fact that Joe Biden
they think in their mind is the only
Democrat that can beat president Trump
in a rematch I don't know if that's true
but I do think the last thing I would
say is what you mentioned about the Wall
Street Journal editorial board that if
the question gets to be well if Biden's
in cognitive decline of some rate and
Kamala Harris is the option then does
that motivate Republicans to vote more
as Democrats are less enthusiastic in
which case as kellyanne Conway said on
the Big Show over the weekend that
actually could help Republicans no
matter who it is great Point all right
I'm going to go to you now Harold you
know he says he needs to finish the job
as Dana just mentioned and he can tout
all the great things that he's done like
massive new infrastructure the president
is doing his job well apparently they
say that the economy is humming and that
there are so many jobs available do you
think that's selling uh the American
people are buying it well first we're
going to be back with you around New
York you as well Greg as always the I'd
say a couple things uh the country's
divided uh there seems to be little
enthusiasm for either of the Front
Runners I'm 52 I don't recall a time
when 70 of the country doesn't want the
incumbent president to run and 60
percent of the country doesn't want the
front runner and the Republican party to
be denominator seems to be age is the
primary factor with uh President Biden
and perhaps some of the noise around
former president Trump as a reason for
that wherever you may stand in the race
two Ron DeSantis was leading in some
polling a month and a half ago two
months ago to Greg's point I think
generic polling uh everybody thinks that
you can have better and do better and we
we believe that we can have someone
personified better what we want politics
if we don't know if we don't know a name
I do believe that if the two of them are
the nominees Donald Trump and Joe Biden
I hope they don't do what some think and
I think they do very well which is bring
out the very worst in their supporters
and I think bring out the worst
sometimes in the country whether they
intend to or not I hope that they
understand they need to elevate the
campaign
said before and I got criticized a
little bit on the panel and perhaps some
of our viewers I think choice for
Democrats is an incredibly important
issue it continues to perform well on
the ballot and I think even if it's Joe
Biden or someone else that issue will be
a defining issue for for Democrats going
forward regardless if it's partly
because there's going to be state
referendums in the key States like in
Ohio for example unless the Republicans
can block that well there's no doubt but
no six I ran for Senate Republicans led
by some in the white house that you
served in Dana put same-sex marriage
referendums on the ballot all in that
the try to generate support so these are
time-honored traditions of doing this
and it will I think whatever the case it
will benefit Democrats but there's no
doubt we've never seen a moment where 70
percent of the party the same party
doesn't want their incumbent or the
country to know what that person to run
and 60 on what the other side of
everyone we'll see how this plays out
you know it's interesting when the
Democrats start pushing they say that
you know and I was reading this this
afternoon he can appear above The Fray
if he delays the announcement and they
they said he had a daring uh Voyage into
Kiev he was greeted like a hero in his
motherland Ireland first of all a daring
Voyage into Kiev when they had those
fake sirens and nobody even looked to
see if there are any bombs coming I mean
how much can you Gaslight
well look you you can't go overseas and
then not go to East Palestine people pay
attention to those types of things you
know I was actually there over the
weekend and why didn't they go visit
those people those people vote they care
they're Americans look cognitive decline
is palpable I mean everybody notices it
and if the Democrats think that more
cowbell more Joe Biden is actually going
to solve their problems that's not going
to solve their problems they're on the
wrong side of the issues they've got
somebody who can't speak and I don't
think it's a coincidence by the way that
Susan Rice departed 24 hours before Joe
Biden I wouldn't be surprised what does
that tell you because I I think she
actually might be a candidate I don't
think Joe Biden even though he may
announce tomorrow I don't think by the
time you get to the end of the year he's
actually going to run and when they
switch the calendar so South Carolina
goes before Iowa and all this that was a
move by the Congressional Black Caucus
and I think somebody like Susan Rice
who's got strong credentials with Obama
and with Biden looks at that and says
why aren't I the president
Susan Rice is going to take on Kamala
Harris for the nominee I think I think
there is a chance I'll watch it I wanna
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now